[Music]
what's up everyone
well here all to simulation we are gonna
be talking about our thoughts on sorry
to bother you which is a new movie that
was just released that was based here in
the Bay Area and shot in Oakland Ron and
I just went and watched it we're excited
to talk about it with you and before we
start we are going to show you the
trailer enjoy
[Music]
then what I'm doing right now I won't
even matter baby baby it will always
manage my money God made this land for
all of us greedy people like you want to
hog it to yourself and your family and
me and my family
yeah Cassius I'm your uncle I just
really need a job for y'all to stick to
the script Cassius green here sorry to
[ __ ] let me give you two you want to
make some money here use your white
Louis my white boys never talking about
Will Smith wife thank this young man
hey mr. Kramer this is Langston from
regal view as always we'll be getting
that out to you right away
you're doing so good with the voice
you're going upstairs power caller they
even have their own elevator welcome
power caller I hope you did not
masturbate today we need you sharp and
ready to go loaded my power color okay
so they're not selling we certainly know
there's no amount of money that make me
do that here's the starting salary man
I'm gonna have to get me some new suits
I can't ride with you I'm doing
something I'm really good at - I'm gonna
make you a proposal I can see that you
want to say no but I wouldn't do that
before you see what I'm offering you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah that
all right you're on go ahead awesome so
that was a that's a pretty good trailer
in terms of describing what the movies
like and I'm really happy that it was
shot here in the Bay Area and there's
definitely some scenes of like the bar
and their scenes of the downtown Oakland
City area and you can totally see that
it is there's some really interesting
morals that are you know brought forth
in that movie that you know Ron and I
haven't even talked about it yet we
purposely didn't talk about it we walked
home from the movie theater to the
studio and we didn't once talk about it
and purposely so because now we can talk
about it fresh and so you know I'm
looking over at Ron and looking over at
you guys as well let's look at the
camera
totally totally but I also want to you
know see what you're saying when you do
say it some of my first thoughts before
before so for you guys so I think
obviously go watch the movie which we're
not gonna like spoil too much for you
but something that comes to mind is that
there is this massive class of people
that need work and what I mean by
needing work is that they'll go and
they'll do whatever they can to get a
job and because they have to live and if
you have to pay rent in order to have a
house over your head if you have to pay
for food to pay for these things then
you have to go and get a job doing
whatever it is now this is pending
things like universal basic income maybe
you won't necessarily need to do work
that is unfulfilled maybe you can do
more fulfilling work maybe you can you
know double up on your money thanks to
ubi and whatnot but right now there's a
whole class of people that are literally
Oh Ron Ron we got a little all right
we're just we're just making a little
bit of pasta pasta so just go ahead and
yeah you can probably move that well
should work yeah when you get so-so yes
so that's so that's one thought about
it's just this whole class of people
just really needing work and that means
usually doing things they don't love to
do there's you were walking in the in
the trailer that they were doing
telemarketing so there's this whole
business in you know picking up the
phone and calling people and trying to
sell them [ __ ] and I don't know exactly
how
much how often you get a phone call and
you're like oh yeah you call it the
perfect time I was looking for just that
thing you know maybe 1% of the time so
if one percent of all telemarketing is
actually targeted and is it is correct
and makes sense then then maybe we
should just stick to that one percent
because the 99% of times you're getting
phone calls you're like you know I got
bigger things to do I'm like my family's
dying or I got like some sort of a
pressing deadline to do or etc all these
different sorts of stories so using your
white voice was very funny the fact that
you know if you yeah go ahead I don't
you know how to do a movie review when
you say using your white voice yeah I
mean yes they can get in well another
well thank you so much for picking up
the phone let me try and chime in on
Ronnie Ronnie I move the lid if you
don't let me get a shot of it ya see so
I can that we're cooking for pasta right
here and the water is boiling over I get
it yeah cuz that's gonna that's gonna
wreck the hot plate yeah so we'll just
get a new one it's good for the economy
all right so anyway i earlier today we
made a video that said we were heading
to AMC theater to watch sorry to bother
you I asked him what's it all about he
didn't know I didn't know I just knew
that it was produced here in the Bay
Area and it might have been surrounding
that you know the the about a black man
in Oakland and I wasn't expecting it to
be somewhat of a sci-fi movie and then
when we watched it and as it was playing
out the first thing that resonated with
me is that this movie is speaking
directly to me and the stuff that we're
involved in where we are in life and
what's you know what we have we're very
ill financed on what we do and also when
we walk to the theater and back to the
theater we also see people living in the
streets that would easily sell out to
the devil if they need to just to
survive the movie was suggestive of that
so it was very interesting but the
bottom line is you know in the in the
film
I couldn't distinguish between myself
and Alan you know who was the good guy
the bad guy
in our lives so it's a very good film
that helps you think about so many
things including the future of human
and the possibilities you know we're
talking to scientists who are working on
genetically modifying the human being no
Alan
yeah we are where'd you go oh he's over
there with eat the pasta okay great I'm
glad we can get a shot of that so here
we are in our studio and Here I am and
Alan's gonna come sit back down but it
was um it was a good film and I'm sorry
to interrupt and that was probably rude
of me Alan to keep things moving but you
know we only have ten minutes to review
this film and are you with me out yeah I
was just trying to yeah next time let's
you know we learned our lesson but I
think I was right about just you know
not trying to multitask with with this
at the same time because it just do the
do the doesn't work do this video and no
it doesn't work cuz it interrupted the
video like three times the flow of the
video just uh so what are you gonna do
about it so next time we're not gonna do
that alright so back to conversation so
Ron's right it was very interesting to
see that kind of like the pull the
economic pull that people are gravitated
towards getting a job and like Ron was
saying there's just this this sort of
you know we're very ill funded here and
that you know the we could easily sell
out and go get a job somewhere and
whatnot and so could so many of the
people that are on the streets that we
walk by on the we're there and back but
they're not they're choosing to do what
they want with their time instead so
it's very interesting there's this using
your white voice was kind of funny
because you know in China you have to
use your Chinese voice because otherwise
you won't make sales you can't use a
white voice or a black voice in China
but in the u.s. you need to use your
white voice because you guy that's how
you make a sale in the u.s. in many ways
but if you do call a neighborhood that's
predominantly Hispanic or predominantly
black you got to use your yard you got
to you know those are the people that
are gonna sell you got to use their
voices that's the whole idea of
relatability and culture so that was
very interesting so was the dichotomy
between rich and poor as well as the
work that is just amazing it's it's
that's what was said here morally
emaciated will just work that's morally
thin it just it makes you feel bad
winging it and so you know we won't
spoil kind of like the morally bad work
what exactly that was but just the
general idea is that this guy got
promoted to a power collar and then he
started selling things that were really
really morally bad and the general ideas
are you gonna trade your soul and trade
money for selling things that are really
bad for the world but then it's
interesting Lee enough arounds right it
went into some sci-fi genetic
engineering realms which is very
interesting and we can talk it was kind
of a fictitious present-day with the
what's the name of the company worryfree
yeah III is the company when they talk
about its its enslavement it's just
simple enjoyment you know you sign a
life contract and you work for this
organization and so it's it's definitely
possible with all the people living in
the streets and just people living in
poverty they want a better life and they
would easily sell their souls should
they be weak with doing that personally
I've had the opportunity to sell my soul
on several occasions before I I just
back away and keep moving and stick to
my guns and go on the principle but I'm
sure I think they got me anyway I think
somewhere along the line they tricked me
they fooled me
so I'm there already there's another
interesting point about this regarding
human capital is that right now like you
were saying you can sell your life away
to this company called worryfree they'll
provide you with food and housing and
all you got to do is just work 14 hours
a day and stuff and it's just you know
very strange in that sense it just
barely gives you any time to you know
two hours free time it's eight and eight
hours of sleep and that's it we look at
what this general this general idea this
of human capital being completely
shifted over time is so interesting
because at this point human capital
seems to be more and more going towards
the direction of automation and if so
many jobs get automated human capital is
gonna be completely different and this
notion that a human is not enough in
order to achieve a certain task but now
you need an Augmented human to be able
to successfully achieve that task like a
human that is
you know buffed up a human that has
stronger mutton bones
your muscles stronger metabolism
stronger brain and so that idea is also
very interesting because this has a
conversation of consciousness involved
in it too if we know that that being is
not conscious then is it okay to have
millions of these beings going and doing
all this physical harder work that us
humans just can't do as well well maybe
it is maybe it's not in the sense that
maybe they are conscious maybe we are
treating them like slaves and we won't
want to be in that position and then the
whole conversation about automation in
the way that a super intelligence would
treat us similarly to how we would treat
these genetically engineered beings so
there's this whole interesting
conversation about that in general well
you obviously got a lot more out of the
film than the average person that what
if one seated I just wanted to be
entertained and I was why you think you
definitely caught on to the genetic
engineering and yeah they're gonna [ __ ]
us no matter what we do so yeah that's
definitely an interesting part of the
more morality of the story I really
appreciated that part of the morality
and then there was this other part of
the morality that about a minute okay
but if you actually fix because real
quick real quick this part of the
morality where you continuously desire
more you live in a garage okay great you
hustle really hard and you earn a
one-bedroom apartment and then all of a
sudden you see your friend has a three
bedroom apartment and you're like well
what the [ __ ] I need a work harder and
get a three bedroom apartment you get
three bedroom apartment and then you see
your friend's house that has a pool and
you're like [ __ ] it I need to get a
house that has a pool and so you're just
constantly getting these upgrades and
materials and possessions from a beat-up
car to a normal Prius to a Maserati or
whatever and you're just going up from
from never flying a plane to flying in
coach to flying in business class to
flying in a private jet etc there's all
these [ __ ] steps up and you're
constantly you know that's just it's
actually completely it's so [ __ ]
crazy that people live in these
different sort of social strata in that
sense and so there was a really good
moral principle in that he ended up I'm
not gonna spoil it so anyway that's the
end of our quick thoughts on sorry to
bother you thanks a lot for tuning into
our thoughts on series on this movie
definitely go out
the trailers in the bio we left it there
for you much love everybody thanks Ron
and join us join us comment below let us
know your thoughts and join us on
patreon so you can continue doing cool
things like this much love everyone
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]